よろしくお願いします
では早速話に入りますけど
今日のテーマはそれほど難しいテーマではございませんと思います
まあ大体我々 私はいろいろ厳しい言葉とかね
まあ言ったりしますから
そこら辺ちょっと鍵かけられています
この私は言いたいところはだいたいこの前にもっと丁寧な文章で読み上げられたので
そこら辺は一応省いていただけます
で 仏教って何なのかというと
心の安らぎをまず解くんですね
それから究極的な幸福というものは説いています
決してこの仏教は嫌いだ
嫌いだ 嫌だとかね 思っているのはこの世の中の普通の思考なんですけど
それも誤解の結果で 間違いの結果で
まあ誤解するんだったら
間違いするんだったらとことん間違ってやるぞという感じで
徹底的に仏教を間違って理解しているんですね
すごい暗い考え方だと
社会に対しては迷惑だと
発展には発展を妨げているんだとかね
それはまあ 日本だけではなくて
他のいろんな もう特に西洋の世界で
もうかなりそういう風に学者の間では批判されてきたものなんですね
で まあそういうことで
このまあいろいろ他宗教の方々も
仏教の国々で伝道活動するときでも
その武器を持って あんた方はもう世界は否定しているんだ
生きていることは否定しているんだ
ですから 社会の発展に対しては迷惑だと
生きていることは空だと思ったら
どうにもならないのではないかと
そういうふうな批判もあります
で それはすべてが読み違いなんですよ
で とにかく欠点を見ようという気持ちで
批判してみようという気持ちで読んで
適当 適当なところで 1行
2行取って まあそれからまあ言いたい放題のことを語っちゃうだけなんですね
ですから ちゃんと証拠を出して語っているわけでもないんです
だからはっきりとお釈迦様が自分が何をおっしゃってますかと
はっきりと明言しています
人間の悩み 苦しみをなくすための道を説いているんだと
憂い 悲しみをなくすための道を説いているんだと
智慧の開発のための道を説いているんだと
心の平安 安らぎ 解脱を体験するための道であると
だからお釈迦様の教えはそういう道であって
それがはっきりと一番古い経典の一番古い層のストレータというか
まあそこら辺に入っているのにも関わらず
一応仏教っていうのはまあ暗い教えだなというふうに
まあその考え方は頑固と消そうとはしないんですね
ですから まあ私もまあこういうところで
ものすごい激しく まあそこら辺はもうポイントをね
徹底的に言ってますけど
まあそれでも人生も生き方も何でもまあ暗く見るという傾向はなかなか治らないんですね
で 修行を実践してみても
人生は明るくなくなるところか
もうさらに落ち込んで小さく狭くなるような傾向も見えるんですよ
そこはまあ もしかすると
その固定概念はとても大事にありがたく思っているからかもしれませんね
ですから まず一番最初に冒頭として言いたいのは
ブッダの教えは幸福の教えであると
安らぎの教えであるということなんですね
心の平安 心の安らぎ そのための教えなんです
皆様方はよくお読みになっていらっしゃると思いますけど
大四念処経 大四念処経は始まるのも
この悩み苦しみをなくすために
憂い悲しみをなくすために
一つの道しかありませんと
ですから その場合もはっきりしていますよ
で ブッダは幸福を語っている人だということは
安らぎを語っている人だということはよくわかると思います
そこで私はずいぶん自慢するところがございまして
それは人類の歴史上現れた初めに現れた世界宗教はブッダの教えなんですよ
今 世界宗教というのはものすごいたくさんありますけど
仏教というのはすごい小さくて
もう誰も信じてくれない
バカにされるようになってますけど
世界で初めて 人類の史上初めて
この世界宗教というのを作ったのはお釈迦様なんです
それはどういうことかと
宗教学的に考えるとお分かりになると思いますけど
世の中に実際に今まであるいろんなたくさんの宗教がございまして
すごい古い このもうゼンラヴェスタとかね
信仰しているこの元イラン人
イラン人の元の宗教 ゾロアスター教とかね
それから時代的に少々遅れているインドにあるバラモン教
ヒンドゥ教とかね また歴史すごい古い
まあユダヤ系統のね まあその旧約聖書を基にして頑張っているね
その教えとか それから新しい時代に現れたイエス様の新約聖書を基にしているキリスト教とかね
それから中国でも宗教的な思考が確かにありましたんでしょうし
老子やら孔子とかね 孟子とか
そういう方々の宗教というふうにあんまり言いづらいかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり結局は経済学でもなくて
政治学でもないんだから
まあ生き方を教えているんだから
やっぱり宗教にした方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますね
それからインドで皆様あまり知られていないし
インド以外 インド国以外は出ていてない
もう一つの大変 哲学的にはなかなかできている宗教がございます
ジャイナ教というね その宗教もお釈迦様より古いんですね
それから一番最近現れたのはイスラム教なんですね
で その諸々の宗教の中
ちょっと観察してみると
この国際性というのは乏しいと思いますよ
なぜかというと 例えばヒンドゥー教というのはカースト制度がございまして
このカースト制度というのはインド社会のシステムなんですよ
神様がバラモン人をまず作って
それからワイシャシュードラ
シャトライ ワイシュードラという４つのカーストを作って
それが人類ですよと そういうふうに言った途端
それがインド人人 インド人の宗教になってなるんであって
日本人の宗教ではなくなっちゃうんですね
だって日本では一人のバラモン人もいないし
シャトリ族もワイシュ族ももうなかなかいないんだから
中国人の宗教でもなくなっちゃうんですよ
そこでその元バラモン教
今のヒンドゥー教 その中にあるしきたり
習慣 儀式 儀礼 すべて見ると
やっぱりこのカーストやらインド人の文化とかね
それは激しく効くんですよ
それでなんでヒンドゥー教は世界で知られているようになったかというと
それウパニシャッドの思想なんですよ
ウパニシャッドはもう一応哲学を語ろうと努力しましたから
その点で なんですよ ですから
徹底的に初めから国際宗教ということではないし
で ユダヤ教はどうでしょうかといえば
はっきりわかっている
それはユダヤ人の宗教であって
イエス様ももうあちこちでやっぱり民族主義的なことを喋ったりもするし
まあ愛というね まあ無制限の愛を語ってはいらっしゃいますけど
もしかするとユダヤ文化からね
責められちゃって いろいろそこら辺はまあセンシティブっていうかね
制限された可能性もありますね
言葉を もしかすると その方がね
もうものすごい革命的で
人類に対する限りない愛を語りたかったかもしれませんですが
聖書の中ではなかなかそこら辺はもう削除されているか
言わせなかったか どちらかでしょうし
イスラム教にしたっても
ものすごい民族主義なんですよ
で もう万人に共通という風にはなかなか見えないんですね
その性格っていうのは
それから中国のまあまあまあ
老子の思想やら そういうものはやっぱり中国人の特色の思想になってしまって
老子の教えはなかなかね
立派なもので すごい普遍性と哲学性はありますけど
結局 孔子の教えやらね
道教やらね そういうものはやっぱり中国的なものなんですね
では 日本の伝統的なね
すごい古い宗教である神道って何でしょうかという
それは日本人だけの宗教なんですよ
外国に教えることはできません
言ったっても笑っちゃうと思いますよ
伊勢神宮をお参りしましょうと言ってもね
外国人にとっては別に何の興味も何のこともないんでしょうに
でお釈迦様は初めて人類には差別はないんだと
人類は一色だよと お釈迦様は他の生命と比べるんですよ
もうカラスと犬は違う
動物と人間は違う でも人間の間で何が違いますかと
全く何もないでしょうと
ですから人類はもう一つですよと
一色ですよと 一種ですよと
それで語った言葉の中で
一言葉も民族性っていうのはないんです
人々のために そういうふうに語ったんですよ
人類のためにと それだけじゃないんですよ
次元はもっと広いんです
お釈迦様おっしゃるの
この教えが人間だけではなくて
人間よりみんな拝んでいる
尊敬している 怯えている神々であろうとも
これ勉強してみなさいと
これが真理だよと ですから
神々でも自分の心を救われたいと
安らぎを味わいたいと
苦しみたくないと思うならば
ブッダの教えを実践するしか方法はないと
それぐらい大胆に語っているんですよ
それでお釈迦様が人ぐらいの悟った方々ができたところで
みんなあっちこっち歩いてくださいと
二人で行くなよという解釈もありますし
二人で行けという解釈もあるし
どちらでもいいんですけど
一応人だから 一人で一人で行ってくださいと
インドは広大な国だから
歩いて このアーディカルヤナンマジェカルヤナンパリオーサナカルヤナンという法を説き解いてくださいと
初めも大変素晴らしい
美しい教えである この悲観的な教えではないんです
エクセレントというカルヤナということを英語で訳すればね
エクセレント ナイス という意味なんですね
ですから このこの何といいます
この初めから初めも美しい
教えの真ん中の心もところも美しい
終点も終わりも美しいんだと
その美しい教えを教えてくださいと
チャリタビクシャチャーリカン
それからバフジャナヒターヤ
大勢の人々のために 幸福のために
バフジャナスカーヤ幸せのために
アッターヤ 意味のあるもの
アッターヤスカーヤヒターヤ
デーヴァマヌッサーナ
人類と神々の幸福の幸せのために
意味のあるこの教えを広げてみなさいよと
なんでそんなことをしたんですかって？大きな宗教組織作りたいではなくて
お釈迦様にあった この無量の慈しみ
美しさなんですね その慈しみに基づいてみんな苦しんでいるんだ
みんな悩んでいるんだ
みんなもう道がわからなくて
幸福の道がどこにあるかとわからなくてもがいているんだと
ですから歩きなさいよと
それで何もものを持たない比丘サンガを設定したんです
比丘サンガの唯一の目的は
仏教を語って歩き回ることなんです
それに褒めてもらわなくたっても
決して仏教を語る人々はもう全然それで機嫌が悪くなることでもないんです
逆に聞いてくれたら それはすごくありがたい
感謝する 聞いてもらわなかったんだからといって
別にご褒美狙ってやっているわけでもないし
まあそれはあまり気にしない
反論すると機嫌が悪くなることは全くない
反論するのは当たり前であって
思考は間違っている 違っているんだから違う思考だから
反論すると できるだけ親切に丁寧に答えようとする
だからって 仏教のお坊さんたちというのは
すごくもうぐにゃぐにゃ性格で
みんなにも言われたい放題言われるかというと
それはそうじゃないんです
真理を語っているんだから
すごいまっすぐ語る 人が単なる反論のために
ただ面白おかしく遊びたいだけのために反論しちゃうと
その場でそれは潰しちゃうんです
知りたくて いくら仏教をいじめても
とにかくこの人は知りたがってるんだと
ですから 教えるのはこちらの義務だよということで教えてあげます
だからといって だからそこはちょっと注意ですけど
我々はいつでも親切な言葉を語ってくるという
そういうことはちょっと約束できません
時々もう心に刺せるようなことも言ってしまう
で それでもやっぱり私たちは責任を持ってしゃべってますよ
たとえ社会批判しても
個人に対してすごい傷つくことを言っても
それには責任持ちます
なぜそう言ったんでしょうかと
ですから 人を叱って逃げることはしません
違ったら まあそれはちゃんと処理もします
そういうブッダの教えなんですね
ですから そこら辺をよく理解していただきたいんです
世界で初めて現れた世界宗教であって
なぜ世界宗教かというと
どんな人間にもこれは実践して心の安らぎを味わうことはできるんです
それで仏教を語ることになったら
なんで人間苦しみのかなんで人間がそんなに心が重いんですかと
なんで悩むんですかと
そこら辺は全部手術して摘出しなくちゃいけないんですよ
摘出するというんですか
取り出さなくちゃいかないんですよ
それがちょっと痛いかもしれません
みんなちょっと戸惑うのはそこら辺だと思います
そういうふうに語っている教えなんです
それである王様がお釈迦様のところに行ってこう言うんですよ
あんた方にはね ろくに住むところもない
いろんなところでお寺とかありましたけど
まあどこでもあったわけじゃないんだから
旅をしているんだからね
木の下でも公園ででも
どこでも横になって寝るとかね
ちゃんと毎日ご飯いただくということでもない
たくさん持ち物もない
もう三衣しか持ってない
お金もない 何もない 家族もない
でも ブッダとブッダの弟子たちの顔を見ると
ものすごく明るく輝いているんだと
いつでもなんとなくかすかな微笑みがあるんだと
で 私は他の宗教の人々もでも王様だからね
付き合ったり 話したり
説法を聞いたりしますよと
でも みんなものすごいきつい顔をして
すごい苦しい顔をしているんだと
ものすごい真剣 真面目な顔をしているんだと
すごく硬いんだと なんか強引で嫌で
誰かに脅迫されて修行しているような感じだよと
なんでブッダの弟子たちがそんなに明るくて
そんなにも気楽で輝いてますかと
お釈迦様の答えは私たち
私にも私の弟子たちにも
心の中で 今のテーマにまとめて言えば
何のストレスもないと
期待することもないし
希望することをしてしがみついて頑張るということもそんなことでもないし
心配することも何もないし
心は安らぎを味わっているんだ
だからみんな結構明るいんだよと
で 仏弟子たちがすごく明るいということは
もうかなり仏教のことを噂になるときはよく噂になったことなんですね
時々批判的な噂っていうのは
あの人々はかなり楽をしているんだと
それにお釈迦様は反対しません
そうですよ 我々 我こそ楽をしているんだと
我こそ人生楽しんでるんだよと
堂々とそれを肯定するんです
ちょっとこれはよくない
宗教家だからね そんな楽をしてはいけませんとか
もうちょっと真剣にみんなに批判されないように修行らしくしなくちゃいけないと
そんな見栄はないんです
世界に褒めてもらうために苦行に励むとかね
断食に励むとか みんなに拝んでもらいたく
もうなんとか行をするとかね
それはない それで批判されちゃったら
あんた方はね よくご飯も食べて
まあ一食でしたけど まあそれもご飯食べて
毎日何の苦行もしないで贅沢楽をしているのではないか
お釈迦様は何のこと？我こそ
楽ですよと ある日 まあちょっともうちょっと論争になりまして
あんたそんなに楽というならば
コーサラ王様の方がもっと楽だよと
だってものすごい大きな国を治めて
ものすごい財産の持ち主で
美人いっぱい自分の宮殿にいて
あれほど贅沢するその人が楽ですよと言ったら
お釈迦様はすぐ違ったんで
いい加減なことを言うなよと
物事を言うならば ちゃんと論理的に証拠を出して語るべきですよと
誰が楽ですかと で それでお釈迦様がこう聞くんです
このこの王様にたった一瞬でも
たったまあ瞬間でもね
今風に言えば １秒２秒でもね
何もややこしいことを考えないで
何も悩むことを考えないで
心に心にかすかにも邪魔する苦しみを作る
もう憎念雑念が全部消されて
穏やかな気持ちでいることできますかと
何も思考しないで それから絶対徹底した絶対的な安らぎを感じながら
1分で見られますか？と言ったら
これは無理と 政治やらなくちゃいけない
いろんな管理しなくちゃいけない
いろんな判断しなくちゃいけない
寝たってもろくに寝られない
それでお釈迦様はこう言うんです
私は 1 分だけじゃなくて
1時間でも 2 時間でも 1
日でも 2 日でも 3 日でも
時々 1週間もそういるんだよと
ずっと 心に何の思考も成り立たない
何の概念も生まれない
で すごい安らぎを感じる
体でも心でも いわゆる微かな不純物も入らない純粋に安らぎを感じて
それは 1週間で見られますよと
だから贅沢してるのは誰ですかと
という経典がございます
そういうことですから
仏教っていうのは 心の悩み苦しみをなくすための大変幸福な教えなんですよ
そこでどんな人でも明るくいたいという希望があるんです
楽しく生活したいと それは誰にでも希望
誰でも顔がね ちょっと硬くなってきつくなってはいたくないんですよ
どんな人でも どんな年ででも輝いて生きていきたいという気持ちがあるんです
でも残念ながらできないんです
残念ながらそれできないんです
だから 人間のすべての人間の希望ですよ
それが たとえ文化を作らないで
ブッシュマンという方々みたいに森の中で生活していても
苦しみたくはないんですよ
気持ちよく 明るく 楽しく生きていきたいんです
それは動物を見ても同じことなんです
必死になって苦しみたい
苦しみたいと思う動物はいません
安らぎを探し求めているんですよ
でも 残念なことにそれができないんですよ
だから 唯一の希望叶わない生き方っていうのは無知な生き方です
単純です 生まれた瞬間からもういろんな希望を人間にありますよ
数えられないほど希望はあるんだけど
世の中でずっとすべての生命に共通している希望が
安らぎ 楽しく楽に生きていきたいという希望なんです
それが実現できない我々の生き方っていうのは
智慧の生き方やと言えないんですよ
だからブッダの教えも愚か者というところから始まる初め始めてしまっちゃうんですよ
それに怒ったならば なんでそんなことを言うんですかと
我々はどこら辺頭が悪いんですかと反論すればよろしいのです
そうすると 一つ一つ証拠を出しながら教えてあげる
それを直せばいいのです
そういうことだから 仏教っていうのは
人間が愚か者という状態から賢者になる道なんです
智慧の人間になる道なんです
そういうことで 他の宗教とちょっとちょっと区別して考えていただきたいんですよ
死後 なんとか約束とか
そういうこの遠い未来の約束のために今苦しんでいる生き方ではないんです
それは毎日毎日 ほんのわずかでも智慧を開発して
開発して ああ 自分なりによくできましたと
これぐらい智慧があるんだよと
それで人生は楽になりましたよと
そういう方向で究極的な智慧が開発するまで
一歩一歩前へ進めばよろしいんです
で そこら辺にまた最後に戻りますので
今日のポイントの真ん中の方に入ります
なんで私たちには気楽に生きていられないでしょうか
ということ 私たちにはやらなくてはならないことをいっぱいやるんですよ
ものすごいやるんです
あれもやらなくては これもやらなくてはとか
義務が多い 義理もものすごい多い
それで守らなくてはいけないもの
まああるというともうきりがなくあるんですよ
それから最後にあるのはいろんな希望
もう義務が多いなのに
義理も多いなのに 守らなくてはいけないことが多いなのに
その上希望もあるんですね
それから願望もあります
希望と願望とは少々心理的には違います
同じものじゃないんです
希望もあって願望もあります
その上 それでも大変なのに欲望もあります
欲望は病気なんです 今まで言ったことはもうどうしようもないかもしれません
欲望は病気です 希望と願望と違って
なぜ病気というんですか
例えば 希望が努力すれば叶う可能性はありますよ
欲望はそう叶わないんですよ
ぐるぐると変わりますから
ころころ変わるんです
増えるんです 叶ったなと思ったら
欲望自体が増えてしまって
もう叶ってないんですよ
それが精神的な病気になって
もう大変な苦しみになるんです
ですから 欲望は気をつけた方がいいんです
希望 願望は努力すればもうそれはもうなんとかなるかもしれません
そういうことで我々は大変なんですよ
例えば 義務が多いということはどういうことかと
朝起きたらこれやらなくちゃいけない
料理を作らなくちゃいけないとかね
いろいろ日常生活の中でやらなくてはいけない義務がいっぱいあるんです
よく見てください その義務を果たすために寝るまで時間がかかるんですよ
寝る時も時々いろんなことをやってないんですよ
今日掃除する予定でしたけど
できなかったとかね 今日洗濯もできなかったとかね
明日買い物しておけばよかったのに
明日のためにこれもできなかったとかね
そうやって自分時卒鳥なんですよ
寝る時来て考えてみたら
自分の毎日の義務も完全に果たしてないんです
いわゆる一日かかるんですよ
義務を果たすために それから義理の場合はどうですかね
義理っていうのは 否応なしにやらなくちゃあかんことでしょう
誰かさんの葬式に行かなくちゃいけないとかね
結婚お祝いを贈らなくてはいけないとか
親戚挨拶に行かなくちゃいけないとかね
引っ越しの報告を出さなくちゃいけないと
新しい家を建てたら それは何といいますか
なんとかお祝いというんですね
そういうお祝いをしなくちゃいけないとかね
そういうふうにいっぱい義理もあります
それ忘れちゃうんです
忙しくて 命日は忘れる
墓参りは忘れる それ忘れちゃうと大変なことになりますね
別にお化けが出てきて首を絞めるわけじゃないんだけど
親戚の間で いろんなことを言われる
会社の社長に中元を忘れちゃったら
社長がそれで貧乏になってもホームレスになるわけじゃないんだけどね
どうせ中元にもらうものも全部いらんもんばっかしでしょうしね
もらって迷惑なんですけど
それ忘れたらまた大変なことになるでしょうに
年賀状をみんなに作って
郵便局に持っていくところで
枚でも落ちちゃったら
自分が書いたつもりですけど
行ってない これまた大変なことになります
だからこの義務を果たすのももう大変であって
その上義理も果たさなくちゃあかんでしょう
どうでしょうかね ストレスたまらないで済むんですかね
それで人生は そこで守る世界
いっぱいあります まず出てくるのは家族を守るとかね
それまた大変 自分の収入の資源をね
ちゃんと守っていかなくちゃいけない
それまたすごい大変 会社が倒産しないように
自分の首が飛ばないように
リストラにならないように
これ簡単ですかね 子供が大きくなると不良にならないように
学校でいじめられないように
守らなくちゃいかんでしょ
守られますかね じゃあ両親に何ができますかね？子供が学校でいじめられている
いじめられないようにすること何かありますか？何一つもないと思いますけど
そういうことでもできなくてできなくて
かなりストレスがたまるんですよ
かなり苦しむんですよ
かなり悩むんですよ それでどうでもいい馬鹿げたことを守っちゃうんですよ
それ守ろうとしてまた苦しむんです
どうでもいい馬鹿げたことっていうのは
人間のまあ思考的な生き方ですね
例えば我々は日本人だとかね
日本人を守らなくてはあかんと
人類なんですけど それで人類は民族に分かれて分かれているんですね
それで我が民族ということになって
それを守らなくちゃいけない
母国というくだらん考え方を作って
それまた守らなくてはいけない
そのために戦う みんなに迷惑をかける
かけたらかけられますね
逆にまた それで宗教争いやるんですよね
我が宗教を守らなくちゃあかんと
どうでもいいことですけど
宗教捨てちゃえば簡単なのに
それはしないで 徹底的にまあ守っ守るために戦って
苦しみを味わって死んでしまう
またあります 自分のプライドを守るとか
立場を守るとか そういうどうでもいいこと
何の役にも立たないことを守ろうとする
文化を守ろうとか で 守りきれないんですよ
バーミヤンの仏像は守ったんですかね
世界でね 日本の方も大変それに国連でまあ頑張りましたよ
なんとか守ってあげようと
その関連の会長は日本の方ですからね
ユネスコの まあ普通我々みたいに黙って待っていたわけじゃないです
もうちゃんと もうすごい
それにはもう攻撃ではなくて
ちゃんと反論して まあしゃべるべきところにちゃんとしゃべって
国連も動かして まあものすごく頑張ったんですけど
守られますかね 守られたんでしょうかね
跡形もなく消されちゃったんです
だから結局 人類の遺産で文化遺産でね
まあ守ろうとしたんだけど
結局もう守られなくなる
それが本当に我々に対して大変感情的なものでもあったならば
これだけでも戦争になるぐらいのものなんですよ
イスラエルとパレスチナの戦争っていうのは
そういう守りでしょうに
これは我々のお祈りの聖地だと思って
一つの宗教を守ろうとする
または他の宗教 我々の聖地だよと思って守ろうとする
でも お互いにまあ世界でね
キリスト教生まれた場所でしょうし
イスラム教 ユダヤ教の約束の場所やいろんなことを言うところなんですけど
そこでどれぐらい人が死ぬかというと
なんで平和を語った人が誕生したところで
みんな平和を謳わないんですかね
仲良く人類みんなそちらに行って
仏教の人々もそちらに行ってお参りに
ここで西洋の方で人類に平和を語った人が生まれたんだよと
そこで殺されたんだよと
感動すればいいのに どうですかね
今の状態って そういうふうに人間のもうこの苦しみというのは
この守る意味があろうかなかろうか
何かを守ろうとする 時々
このもう家 歴史のほんのわずか古い
まあもうせいぜいもう年ぐらいでもいいんですよ
古い家にお嫁に行ったら
それでその家の人々は
こちらの伝統を守らなくちゃあかんって
あのお嫁さんいじめる
それで精神的にものすごい苦しみを味わったりする
時々 三代目まで続けた会社だからといって
全く商売にならない ご飯を食べることはできない
収入で それでも苦労して苦労して守ろうとする
だから それで何が得られるかというと
生きること自体が苦しみになる
具体的に苦しみになる
そうやってこの守るということも
一見美しく聞こえることなんですけど
いくら美しく聞こえても
人間の苦しみを作る原因になっていることは頑固たる事実なんです
民族争いってものすごい一番いい例なんですよ
民族の歴史自体もおかしいんですよ
初めから民族を作って
我々はもう 2000年の古い民族だとかね
それで他の民族を殺したりいじめたりする
あるいは同じ民族であろうとも
変な宗教をとってやったら
まあそれで 激しく喧嘩したりする
このボスニアとかね そこら辺の問題っていうのは
民族と同時に宗教争いなんですね
それで ロシアにも一つありますね
どこでしたっけ？地方は
チェチニア？チェチェン
まあ大変でしょうに 殺すは殺されるわということで
それ宗教ですよ チェチェニアはイスラム教だから
もうソ連とは仲良くしたくないと
別に独立したいと だから幸福を作ってくれてるんですかね
そうすると なんで仲良くしないんですかね
人類として 作っているのは苦しみだけでしょうに
そういうで 皆様に私は理解してほしいのは
この何かを守るということも
結局は人間に苦しみ 悩み
ストレス すべてを作ってくれるんだということなんです
だから そういう話をすると大体は怒られますけどね
じゃあ文化壊せと言うんでしょうかとかね
そういうことを私は言っていないのは
私は中道を語っているんだからね
私はではなくて 仏教は
ですから もう何か壊せということではないんですけど
非論理的でくだらないことに戦うなよと
苦しむなよと この間 木曜日
質問されたんですよ どなたかの方から
今日いらっしゃるかどうか分かりませんだけどね
バーミヤン仏像とかね
ああいうニュースを聞くと
すごく腹が立ってくるんだと
なんでそういうことを壊しますかと
私はどう思いますか？私は
私は別に何も思ってないんだと
それほど壊したければいいんじゃないんですかと
それほど私も反対ってやることはもう当然のこと反対ですけど
だからといって それほどアフガニスタンの方々にあの仏像あることは迷惑だったら
アフガニスタンの方々の貧しさ
苦しみがあの仏像のせいだったらね
壊した方がいいんでしょうと
それでアフガニスタンは世界で大変豊かな国になるでしょ
あれが宗教的に問題でしたから
アンイスラミックという偶像崇拝は
今イスラミックでしょ
純粋にイスラム主義的だからね
まあ見てください まあ二
三年でね 世界で肩並べる豊かな国になりますからね
ですから 彼らの思考はそういう思考だから
まあしょうがないでしょうに
放っておけば ですから
私は全然そんなことには怒りも何も感じないんです
ただ悲しいだけ なんてアホな人間かと
そんなことあったってもね
別にかゆくも痛くもないのに
何か仏像やらそれあっただけでイスラム教が壊れるんだったらね
ろくな宗教ではないでしょうと
だからそこら辺の自分たちの屁理屈に気がつかない
その人間の無知 それは悲しい
何もわからない 何も理解できない
何の判断能力もないぐらい
人間としては情けないところは悲しいだけなんですね
逆に楽しいんですよ だってそこまでそんなことまで考えるんでしょうかと
放っておけばいいのにね
だから私も破壊したことを放っておきます
別に気にしないと で また考えればどんなものでも壊れるでしょうに
ピラミッドも壊れるわ
古代文明も壊れちゃったし
もうみんな作るというか
バカでかいものを作るんだけどね
ローマエンパイア ローマ帝国見たっても
まあまあがらくただけでしょうに
まあそういうことだから
まあどんなものを自然の法則の中でも壊れてはいく
誰か壊さなくたっても
まあそういうことだから
まあ落ち着いていられます
腹が立たずにいられます
そういうことで 一応我々のストレスたまる原因
苦しみたまる原因っていうのはそういう原因であります
それで次に このこの機能
どういう機能かというと
私たちには例えば義務が多いでしょうに
義務が多い 義理も多い
それでよく見てください
時間足らないんですよ
1 日の仕事を終了するためにも
1 日の時間は足らない
その上 仕事もしなくちゃいけない
社会的な義理義務も果たさなくちゃいけない
自分の体の面倒を見なくちゃいけない
時間がないんですよ 学校から電話かけてきたら
あなたの子供はちょっとトラブルを起こしましたから
早く学校に来いと で 家で何やっていたっても
料理作っていたっても
天ぷら作ろうと思って全部用意して油ももう温めていた途中かもしれません
それはそのままやめて学校に行かなくちゃいけないんです
すると帰ってきたら食べるものはないと
ということにもなるし
そういうふうに我々にはすごい時間がないんですよ
それどうしますかというと
何一つもろくにしない
どんな仕事も中途半端で
途中でもうやめる で それで心にある問題が起きちゃうんですよ
ジャガイモを皮をむきながら
心がジャガイモに行かないんです
子供のことをどうしようかとか
買い物のことをどうしようかとか
洗濯物は大丈夫かな？とかね
心はそうやって英語でフラクチュエイト言うんですけど
飛び回っちゃうんです
いつでも あっちこっちあっちこっち心が飛び回る
子供も同じことで 学校で勉強する時でも
心がいろんなところに飛び回っている
一箇所にとどまらないんです
仕事をしている時も 将来のことやら過去のことやら
家のことやら いろんなことに心が飛び回る
飛び回っちゃうと仕事は中途半端になる
失敗はする それで３分の仕事には10分以上かかる
1時間で読める本は あっちこっち飛び回る心で読むと3時間もかかる
時間なくなって明日にまでも回されたりもします
考えてみてください 今
すでにも時間がないのに
心が飛び回ることによって
さらに時間取ってしまっちゃう
掃除機 掃除をするために十五分だと決めても
もう十五分ももうもう時間ないぐらいなんですね
十五分かかったら他の仕事に時間がないんですよ
それなのにあっちこち心が飛び回しながら掃除機をかけると
十五分のところを三十分
四十分かかってしまっちゃうんです
さらにひどい状態になるんですよ
これは国の赤字国債と同じなんです
増える一方で 減る見込みはないんだと
どうでしょうかね そうすると我々の生き方っていうのは
一日の義務だけ果たすことでも二十四時間取れるのに
それに上 義理やら他の仕事やらもう守ることやら
もうそれもかかってしまって
もう一日はもう一週間ぐらい延ばしてくれないと
時間足らない状態で それで仕事をすると
それまた三倍時間取ってしまったりする
わざと時間を取る 時間を取る
全て無知な原因なんですよ
この時間延ばすと 私は時々客観的に観察するんですよ
なんて無知かアホかって時々言いたくなるぐらい
単純ではないかと こういう風にすぐ終われるものではないかと
それで時間取ってしまっちゃう
で 心がこの自分 今やる仕事に定着しないことで大変な問題が起きます
どういうことかというと
喜びが消える こういうことなんですよ
私たちは頑張って何か仕事をしたところで
やったぞという充実感が生まれるでしょ
やったぞと それが全然ないんですよ
だって掃除機かけても他のことを考えながら
もう慌てて慌てて早くやっているでしょうに
この早く掃除機かけてるんだから
十五分の掃除機には大体三十分かかってしまっちゃうんですね
そういう分早いんですけど
三十分で料理などできますけど
大体三時間かかります
なぜかというと 早くやっているんだからなんです
それだけじゃないんですよ
あの充実感もないんで
やったぞということ はぁ
やっと終わったというね
ああ 嫌だとかね それで終わっちゃうんですよ
ああ 嫌だ 大変だと だから掃除機終わっちゃうと
どれぐらいストレス 怒り溜まってるかというと
できれば掃除機も畳んで置くんじゃなくて
そのまま捨ててしまいたいぐらい
足で蹴っ飛ばして出て行けと言いたいぐらい
もう ストレスは溜まってるんですよ
料理そこでどれぐらいストレス溜まっちゃうというと
この食器がいっぱいもう洗わなくちゃいけないので
できればそのまま それはもうもう潰して捨てたいぐらいの気持ちなんです
仕事はどれぐらい楽しいかというと
もうもうクビにならないんだったら
もう社長をもうぶん殴っちゃうんです
それぐらいの気持ちです
だから我々の生き方はそういう生き方なんです
だから 誰一人もあの楽しみが味わってない
やったぞという楽しみができたそうと
終わったよと どんな仕事でも
たとえ単純なことでも
きちんと早く上手に失敗なく
やってしまえばなんとなく楽しいんですよ
よくできましたと その楽しみというのは
その充実感なんですよ
その楽しみがあると ストレスはたまりません
ですから 仏教から見れば
普通の人間の生き方っていうのは
苦しみ ストレス 苦しみ
ストレス 悩み そういうものだけ溜も溜まる
溜まる 生き方 少々その生き方を変えれば
瞬間瞬間楽しみを味わう
充実感を味わう生き方にはなります
で 心に対しては 仏教では人間の心っていうのはこの
猿頭だというんですよ
猿頭といえば これ湿津
日本訳は湿津になっちゃうんですね
英語ではマンキーマインドなんですよ
我々の心っていうのは
猿のようで落ち着かなくて
あっちこっちあっちこっち飛び回っているんだと
一箇所に止まれよと 一つの仕事をもうもう真面目にやりなさいよと
終わるまでそれができないんです
だから完全に人生そのものが失敗一つですよ
それはこの心が飛び回っていることなんです
そこで人間の幸せっていうのは
ご飯にあるものじゃないんですよ
座る椅子にあるものじゃないんですよ
幸せっていうのは心の喜びなんです
ご飯食べておいしかったと
その気持ちが幸せであって
ご飯が幸せではありません
お金も幸せではありません
この心の喜びなんですよ
そこで心が喜ぶためにはやりましたと
その自慢が必要なんです
それが自慢かもしれませんだけど
やったよと 終わったよと
その心に認識に その終了宣言必要なんです
この終了宣言しない限り
心が不安定な状態なんです
それはもう微妙なところなんですけど
あの テーマは簡単だから
ちょっと論理的なところばっかり今日喋ってます
あの 微妙なところなんですけど
やっぱりこの仕事をなんか途中で
例えば何でもいいんですよ
途中でやめてみてください
大事な仕事を後にしますと
その時から心になんとなく不安定状態
イライラ状態残るでしょうに
ある 終わらなかった仕事をいくつかあるんだと
この締め切りとかあったりする場合は
まだ自分で仕事をやってない
手を出してない あるいは終わってない
後回しにしている その時
気持ちはどうですかね
確定申告は明日ですですけど
今日もまだ書いてないと
心の状態はどうですかね
かなり激しいんですよ
かなり苦しいんですよ
どんな仕事でも 鼻の先に来たら
まあ今はいいや 明日にするそうとちょっと延期してみてください
心はどうなるかと それで心がすごい不安定な状態になるんです
イライラするんです 楽しみは消されちゃうんですよ
例えば仕事終わるんだけど
やっぱりこれはやめてテレビ見る
見ますよと テレビ見てもテレビも楽しめないんですね
ずっと心が あれ やっぱり
やっぱりやらなくでもテレビ見る
やっぱりやらなくちゃいかん
でもテレビ見るという状態になるんですね
これ終わってからやるんだとか
そうするとテレビを見る楽しみも消されちゃうし
仕事をしなかったことの苦しみもどんどん増えていくし
それで仕事を始めようと思ったら
もう時間ない 時間テレビに取られちゃったんだから
なんで時間ないんでしょうか？とか
また自分を責めたりもするし
その生き方 ですから この幸福っていうのは終了宣言
どんなつまらない どんな小さな仕事でも
終了した瞬間で心がすっごく安らぎ感じるんです
それが誰にでもないんですよ
ですから 私たちは24時間生きてるし
その24時間の中でいろんなことをやってますよ
だから たとえどんなつまらないことでも
やること やること やること
その場でその場で終了すると
そうするとどうですかね
その場でその場で終了する
そうすると その瞬間 その瞬間
安らぎを感じない 喜びを感じない
心に終了宣言をちゃんとインプットしないと
心が安らぎを感じないんです
ブッダの悟りの道もそういう道なんですよ
悟りも開いたら終了宣言するんですよ
自動的に全ての仕事の終了宣言
それほど安らぎあると思いますか？だからぶってみてください
なすべきことは成し終えたと
修行するべきところは全部修行し終えましたと
これからやることないんだよと
これが人里とにできる最高な究極的な終了宣言なんです
それがすべての幸福よりも絶対的な幸福であると
だからニッバーナパラマンスカン
涅槃こそがパラマン 最高たる最初で一番優れているスカン
ハピネス幸福であると
すごい論理的にブッダの教えわかると思います
日常生活の中ででも 我々何かできたら
何か仕事を終わるまで
終わるまでして終了したと
終わったと やったと思った瞬間で喜び感じる
それの延長線ですよ 解脱は
決して変なわからない神秘的なものではありません
そういうことで ストレスはそういうふうに出てきますね
仕事はガタガタにする
途中でやめたりする 後回しにする
それで心がイライラする
不安定な状態になる それですごい
それがストレスなんです
それから人間にはもう仕事多いんだから
1日が1週間に伸ばしてくれても
地球はゆっくり回してゆっくり回しちゃうと燃えちゃいますけどね
それでもいいんだから
ゆっくり回して 1日には1週間の時間をつけてくれても
我々にはまだやり残している仕事はいっぱいあるんですよ
ですから 人間のこの生き方では
ストレスないように生きるといえば
これはもう皆無 無理やというぐらい無理なんですね
それぐらい我々のは あれもやらなくちゃ
これもやらなくちゃ あれもやりたい
これもやりたい その上
願望もあって 希望もあって
毎日忙しいなのに もしその上欲望まで出てきたら
この世で欲望なんかない人間いるんでしょうかね
だから本当は我々はどこまで苦しみにストレスを感じているかというと
もう怖くなるほど感じています
お釈迦様のたとえで言うならば
膨大な大きな穴に炭火を入れて
それ真っ赤に燃えているところで
人の体を矢で刺して その炭火の穴の中に入れてぐるぐる回しているような状態だよと
どこに回しても燃えちゃうんですよ
痛いんですよ だから槍で刺されただけでも大変でしょうに
それであの豚の丸焼きのような感じで
あの その炭火で真っ赤に燃えている
その大きな穴の中に自分を入れて回して回されちゃうと
かなりきついでしょうね
それがお釈迦様がおっしゃっているこのストレスの量なんです
誰でもそれぐらい感じているんです
だから涼しいところは生まれた瞬間からも感じていないんです
だから我々はあまり気にしない
溶岩の中に生まれたような感じで
燃えてはいるんだけど
比較することはないんです
そういうことだから みんなこの
炭火の中にいるんだけど
まあちょっと紙でも一つ背中に貼ってもらっちゃえば
ちょっとすごい気持ちいいやとかね
そんな感じでこの一時的な措置をしていますよ
じゃあ 炭火の中にいる人の背中に紙を一つ
新聞紙一つ貼ってあげると
それで暖かいという 熱いということは消えますかね
瞬間消えますよ でも完璧じゃないんです
瞬間消えるんだけど 次の瞬間
あの新聞紙が燃えちゃうんですよ
燃えちゃうんだからさらに痛いんです
だから我々やっていることはそういうことなんです
いろいろもう何か工夫します
このストレスなくそうと思って
かえってもっと大きなストレスが生まれてくる
その生き方はしています
では 一旦休憩いたします
で 次のところに入ります
どうもありがとうございます
それではまた始まります
私たちの人生っていうのは
そういう風にこの中途半端で生きているんだから
いろいろ失敗をきますから
それから後悔になったりもするし
失敗 また失敗しましたかということで
それから自信もなくなっちゃうんですね
だから本当にこの自信あって生きる人っていうのは
なかなか世の中にないんですよ
いつでも不安というかね
自信がないんですね それもこの一つの
我々の生き方の問題ですよ
瞬間瞬間の仕事を終了宣言までするならば
これが失敗しなかったと
これがよくできたという自信が出てくるんですね
それも人間にはないんですよ
そういう生き方で 次の
ストレスの世界  これからもうちょっと難しくなるかもしれませんだけど
人間っていうのは 仏教は智慧の世界だから
物事を知っておかないとどうにもならないんですね
世界 世界はちゃんと正しく知っておく必要があります
知ったかぶりぶりは大変危険なんですね
知るということは必要なんですよ
で 一般的に我々は知識人だ
現代世界はすごい知識の世界だとかね
昔と今は随分違うんだとか
今は情報の社会だと もう何でも知ることはできるんだぞというふうな
我々現代人にはかなりこの
何て言いますかね これはちょっと舞い上がっているところもあります
ちょっとのところじゃないんですけど
古い人々は馬鹿にしちゃうんですよ
何も知らない 知らないでしょうとかね
そこで仏教からの疑問
あんた方は本当に世の中を知ってますかと
知ったかぶりだけではないかと
という疑問を投げかけているんです
どういうことかというと
我々は何か見ると 何か聞くと
何か味わうと 何か考えると
そのありのままに身を聞こうとしないんです
選ぶんです 好きなもの
好きなものを見ると 好きなものを聞くと
好きなものを味わうと
好きなことをすると 好きなことを勉強すると
というと それはよよう知ることですかね
この人が自分の主観で判断しているだけでしょうに
知ってないんです だから情報っていうのはすごく自然に体に触れるんですよ
情報が別に何のこともなく
何のコントロールもなく
ただ体に触れる でもこちらで何か尺度を作って情報を処理しちゃうんですね
だから私が知っているのは入った情報ではなくて
自分の好みなんです その大変な大きな問題なんです
ですから この固定概念いっぱいありまして
ご飯は美味しいとかね
花は綺麗ですとか で ゴッホの絵はすごい綺麗ですよとかね
で 誰かさんの音楽は一番いいんですよとかね
そういう風にいろいろまず固定概念いっぱい作って
それを追っていく そうすると自分好んだ楽しみが出てこない
例えばこのご飯がおいしいんだと思って食べてみたら楽しくないと思ったら
ああ これにはこれを合わせてあれも合わせてこれも合わせて食べましょうと
そのとこおいしいですよと
強引にその情報を変えるんですよ
あの独裁国の厳密な共産主義の国々の新聞情報と同じなんです
事実ではなくて 自分でニュースを作って言いたいことを言うと
それで私たちもまあなんとかご飯おいしいですよで言って
もうそれ食べてみて ちょっと食べてみて
それからこれに塩をかけましょう
ごまを振りましょう で
何かまた入れましょうとかね
そういうふうにしてわざと変化させて食べる
それで見るものをわざと変えて見る
だから自然破壊もいいところでしょうね
自分の好みで何でも破壊していく
結局は知ってないんですよ
それから好きなものが出てくると
必ずしもそれ以外のものは嫌いなものになるんですね
それで嫌いなものと判断して
その固定概念で世の中を見ると
全部もう反対する 拒絶する
攻撃する 壊しに行く だから世の中を見ていないんです
こちらで嫌いと判断して
その人はどうであろうとも壊しちゃう
そうやって世の中で 例えば宗教は大嫌いだとか平気で言うでしょうね
私の話を聞いたこともない人々はかなり批判するんですね
私は話を聞いてみろと
そんな批判があったら面と向かって言いなさいよと
なんで腰抜けで逃げて隠れて言うんでしょうかと
と言いたいところですけど
知らないんだからね まあどちらでも関係ないんですけど
とにかく自分で嫌いと決めたら全部嫌いと
坊主が憎けりゃ袈裟まで憎いということことわざの通りなんですよ
それで何でも壊しに行く
それで世界知るということにならないんですよ
それでどうなるかというと
我々はものすごく硬くなる
頑固になる 自然を壊す
自然な生き方 それまた壊しちゃう
自然の中で流れて生きるべきなのに
我々は自分の人生っていうのを全て今もうとっくに壊しているんですよ
体のためだと思って 毒しか食べるものはなくなっているし
空気は汚れているし 綺麗にしようと思って建物を造るために使う材料なんかは
いろんな化学物質を出したりして
それまた体にも悪いし
なんでそうなるんでしょうかというと
自分で好きな方にするんだから
なんでも 好きな方に変えようとする
嫌なことは変えようとする
それで世の中知られなくなります
それは仏教でいう大変有名な人間の心の中の感情ですね
むさぼりと怒り これがすごいストレスになるんです
欲を作ってみてください
すごいストレスなんです
人に恋でもしてみてください
うそインチキな歌なんかはなんと美しいやと
とんでもないんですよ
かなり精神的にストレスかかるんです
ものすごい精神的にストレスかかるんですよ
欲が生まれたら 怒りを作ってみてください
打ちつけますかと あれが嫌
これが嫌とかね ずいぶんわがままで自己本位で嫌なものをいっぱい作ってみてください
もう生きていられなくなります
ものすごいストレス溜まっちゃうんです
それで知ることもできなくなる
それから我々はもっとすごいことをするんですよ
無視するということをするんです
情報が触れるんだけど
無視する 好きでもないんだから
嫌いでもないんだから
まあ流しちゃう 無視する
この無視することは仏教では無知と言うんです
で 私たちはこの世界を知るではなくて
貪瞋痴で世界を変えようとしているんです
好きなものは追っていく
嫌なものは壊しに行く
他のものは無視して馬鹿になる
知らないんだ そんなことは
気にしなかったと 平気で無視する
その 3つで 心の中で貪瞋痴という硬い性格が出来上がっちゃうんです
それですごい頑固で もう硬くてもう曲げない人間になるんです
いろいろ私はあれだこれだとか
大変好き嫌い激しいやと言ったら
その人とは付き合うことさえも難しいでしょうに
折れないんだから 柔軟性がない
もう硬い その人がそれから自分と戦わなくちゃいけない
世界と戦わなくちゃいけない
戦えますかね それですっごくストレス溜まる
だからストレス溜まるもの
根本的な原因は この貪瞋痴というむさぼりと怒りと無知というこの 3つなんです
何が失うかというと 智慧を失うんです
ありのままの世界は失うんです
ですから 人類は言っていることはまとめて言えば嘘です
簡単に言えます 例えば
科学発展こそ人間には素晴らしいやというと
全然幸福になってないでしょうに
全然我々に余裕も安らぎもないでしょうに
発展はしていますよ 確実に
いっぱい道具は作ってはありますよ
じゃあ暇がありますか？人生それで楽しいんですか
新しいものを作れば作るほど
ものすごい馬鹿下たく高くて手に手に入らないんですよ
そうすると 今までの仕事量はさらに倍にして仕事をしなくちゃいけないんです
あの約束だけのリーニアモーターカーというものがね
もし商売始めたら やっぱり望むよりも 3倍給を払わなくちゃいけないんですよ
大阪に行くために そうすると私たちはもっと仕事をしなくちゃいけないんですよ
そうするともっと時間なくなっちゃうだけなんです
結局嘘ですよ 言っているのは科学的なもの
発展すればするほど 人間がそれで幸せになるんだと言って逆なんですよ
それで大変で生きていられなくなるだけなんです
なんでそうなるかというと
全て貪瞋痴で考えるんだからなんです
この間  NHK で見たんだけど
この手術ロボットを開発しているんです
あれ見たらまあ素晴らしい技術だと
体を切りません  ３箇所で穴開けて
穴から細い管を入れて
一つはカメラ 一つは光とカメラ
もう一つで 2つでちゃんと手術をする
切るところは切って取るところは取り出しちゃって
ロボットが体の中で縫うところも縫ってくれる
そこであの細い管を出せば
小さな穴みそだから それ閉めればいいんです
だから患者さんには確かには負担はない
その私は本当にあれはすごいと思いますよ
でも問題はあの機械の値段なんですよ
普通の人には手術を受けられません
かなりお金がないと 普通 10万円で払って済むものだったら
あの機械を使って手術したらやっぱり 40 万
50 万になるんです で
まあ幸せなことには保険きかない
ですから まあ考えてみてください
とにかく新しい技術だから
まあ広げるだろうと思いますし
人間にとってはいいことだから広げるだろうと広げてほしいしね
私でも でも私の考え方を見れば
もうどんな病院でもそういう機械があって
誰にでも簡単にその恩恵を受けられるように
した方がいいでしょうに
それだったら このロボットを開発した人々はすごい苦労して開発していたんだから
その人々には各国の政府やら
もういろんな資金を出して
じゃあどうぞお金あげるんだから
これからお金を取るなよと
あっちこっちでみんなでそれ作りましょうと
これ人類のためになるんだよと
買えない人々にももう買えるようにしてあげましょうと
そうやって人類にちょっとだけでも安らぎを作ってあげようというところなん
するべきところなんですけど
逆に特許を取られて ものすごいお金を払わなきゃ買えないし
病院も商売やらなくちゃいけないんだから
もう高いお金 料金取らないとできなくなるし
やっぱり一見いい技術なんですけど
またそのために我々はさらに働かなくちゃいけない
さらに時間なくさなくてはいけないと
それから人類の一部だけその恩恵を受けて
大勢の人々はその恩恵を受けない
という世界になる だからなんでそうなるか
貪瞋痴でしょ あの人は買えないんだから死んでもいいやと
私たちは儲かるためにそれを作っているんだと
儲かってどうするんですかね
儲かる儲かるという言葉自体おかしいんですよ
それ自体恐ろしいんですよ
それでみんな苦しんでいるんだから
気持ちよく 楽しく 仲良く
みんなで生きていれればいいでしょうに
でも貪瞋痴はそうさせません
絶対儲からなくちゃいけないんだと思って
相手の財産も能力もすべて搾取する
奪う 盗む ですから この世の中は貪瞋痴で考えているんです
それで哲学作る それで我々の生きる方法を教える
すべてもう逆さまなんです
だから見てください 世の中の人々の話を真面目に聞いた
みんな聞いているでしょうに
一向に幸せになってないでしょうに
平和平和やとみんな語っているんですけど
世界には一度も平和が訪れていない
豊かになろう 豊かになろう
貧困をもう取っ払いましょうと
言うことは言うんだけど
こんな豊かな日本ででもホームレスがいる
国のために 国民のためにと政治家
政治の方々言うんだけど
真面目に話聞いて従ってみてください
とんでもないことになる
だからいろんな汚職していられ
ワイロワイロしたり 悪いことしたりすることはなぜバレますかというと
信じてないんだからなんですよ
だから信じてないんだから救われてます
医者のことも完璧に信じてないんだから
なんとかもう医療ミスやらいろんなことを控えて自分を守ることはできます
でなきゃ いくら手術ミスがあったっても
手術は完璧だとカルテ書いちゃえばそれだけで終わっちゃいますから
手術術で何か事故を起こしちゃっても
書かなかったらわからないんだから
誰も知りませんだから
平気で殺されますよ でも一般の人々もやっぱり信頼しませんと
ということだから やっぱりそういうものの問題はちゃんと明らかになって
明確になって それで医者もやっぱり気をつけろということになるんです
訴えるんだ 訴えられるんだから気をつけているんですよ
もし医者を訴えられないということになっちゃうと
もう人類は終わり その生き方なんですよ
世の中の哲学っていうのは
だから結局我々は何で救われていますかというと
人を疑うんだからなんですよ
それ事実でしょうに だから
そんな世界美しいんですかね
人を疑う生き方 人を敵だと思う生き方
人に騙されるんだとずっと神経使って気をつける生き方
楽 でも 我々の現代2１世紀の生き方っていうのは
相手を信頼しない 騙されるかもしれませんとずっと緊張している
病院に行ってもいちいち調べてみる
病気になったらすぐそこら辺に行きましょうということではなくて
調べて調べて病院を行く
私は病院調べること自体大変おかしいと思いますよ
だって悪い病院といい病院も成り立っているんだから
頭の中で それ私が言ったら日本人を馬鹿に
馬鹿にしているんだと
私じゃないんですよ 皆様ですけど
平気で私に言うんだから
いい病院もありまして
悪い病院もあるんだよと
私がおかしいんじゃないんですか
悪い病院があるはずがないでしょうに
ですから 我々はそうやってこの苦しい世界
貪瞋痴のおかげさまでわざと作っているんです
人を裏切らなかったら生きていられない
人をもう裏切るじゃなくて疑う
人を疑わなかったら生きていられない
この人に騙される可能性ありますよと
じっと覚えておかないと大変なことになる
それがね カラスでも群れを作って仲良く生きているのに
犬たちでももう放してあげれば
野良犬になったらきちんと群れを作って
お互いに心配し合って仲良く生きているのに
人間は 互いにみんなもう信頼しない
夫婦の間でも信頼ない
子供は親を信頼しないとか
そういう世界で生きていて
その世界素晴らしいんだと
また無知だからわかってないんですよ
なんて幸せな人生かと誤解
それは無知から言うんですね
ですから この本当に幸せな世界っていうのは
人を疑うんじゃなくて
人を信頼する 人を敵だと思うんじゃなくて
まあもう優しさ なんていい人ですかと
なんて優しい人ですかと
誰を見ても感じられる世界でしょうに
なぜそういう世界ないんでしょうかと
なぜ徹底的にストレスで固まってきているんでしょうかというと
原因はこの貪瞋痴 ですから
お釈迦様はむさぼり 怒りと無知をやめなさいと言ったら
これまたブッダにまで悪口を言うんだから
そんな生き方できっこはないんだとか
おかしいんだとか 不自然だとか
ブッダにまで言うんですよ
誰が不自然ですかね 誰がおかしいことを思っているんですかね
だって欲ばっかしに目がくらんだら自己破壊になるでしょうに
これははっきりした証拠
それしか歴史で 歴史はそれだけでしょうに
昔のバカな政治家たちが自分の国を広げようと思って
いろんな国にも戦いを挑んで
挑んでどうなったんですか？自分まで破壊してしまったでしょうに
じゃあヒットラーさんが世界制覇しました？どうなったんですかね
結局犬みたいに死んでしまっただけで
そうやって欲が 怒りが自己破壊に行くんですよ
それはいくらでも証拠はある
それでもいいと思うのは
お釈迦様はそれは無知のせいだと
観察しないせいだと 世の中ちゃんと見ておきなさい
見ておきましょうと むさぼりで
怒りで この湾曲させて
ないものを知るんじゃなくて
あるものあるがままに知っておきなさいましょうと
そうするとむさぼり 怒りも消える
そうした人にとっては
人間というのは敵じゃなくて仲間なんですよ
騙される人ではなくて
何かあったら助けてくれる人なんですよ
嫌な人ではなくて すごい優しい人なんですよ
だからブッダの教えは
こういう人類みんなもうお互いに
もう家族のように 我がこのように心配し合う
慈しみで触れ合う人々にしたかったんですけどね
あまりスケールは大きすぎですけどね
まあでももう世の中はそうじゃないんだから
うまく仏教っていうのはうまくいかないってことになっています
そこで心の中に貪瞋痴が出てきたら
我々はすぐ硬くなる 暗くなる
欲が出てきたらすごい顔色が暗くなるんですよ
人の話は聞けなくなる
怒りの場合は明確ですけどね
怒りで 憎しみで燃えちゃうと
ものすごい嫌な人間になるんですね
そうすると みんなその人を嫌悪して
もうもう離れちゃうし
他人に愛されないんですよ
そこで仏教ではこの善心処という言葉がありまして
善行為という言葉がありまして
この善行為 良い行為っていうのは
仏教の心理学では善心処が生まれた人が性格は滑らかだと
すごく楽しみを感じるんだと
柔軟性があるんだと 体も心もすごい軽いんだと
活発的になるんだと それからすごい平等で
物事を落ち着いて見ているんだと
その気持ちが徳であって
善神なんですよ 善行為なんです
それなのに善行為してくださいと言ったら
まあちょっと二 三歩ぐらい下がっちゃうんですね
善行為っていうのは 人に柔軟性を与えてくれる
心も体も楽にしてくれる
笑顔を忘れた笑顔を忘れてないんですね
笑ったことないんだから
ですから笑顔というのは生まれてくる
なんとなく気持ちいいということになる
気楽になる 欲が入ったら
怒りが入ったら全く反対ですごく硬くなってしまっちゃうんです
もう嫌な存在になってしまっちゃうんです
だから このアビダンマというね
仏教の心の分析のところで
善 瞋 捨というところが説明してありまして
そちらの言っているのは善心
良い心になったら軽さ
柔軟性 それからタットラマッジャッタタという言葉があります
善心その中でどんなものについても中立的で偏らないで見ているんだと
このタッタっていうのはそこにという意味なんですけど
それはじゃあ見るもの
聞くもの いわゆる我々は見たり聞いたり喋ったりする
そのそのそのその場で
その場でマッジャッタタ中立性を持つんだと
今 我々は物事はいつでも偏って見たり聞いたりしています
偏って考えたりします
それで硬くなる 善心の場合は
善行為の場合は偏らないんです
それが善心なの その場合はストレスというのはひとかけらもないんですよ
だからストレスの人生が悪行為なんです
不善行為なんです 結論として言いますけど
ストレスというのは単なる自然の現象やとかというふうに処理できるものじゃないんです
それ自体悪行為なんです
不善なんです ストレスはない
柔らかい心でいること自体が善
善 善行為 善なんです だからそんな簡単じゃないんですよ
カウンセラーに行って直してくれるぐらいのものやとかね
大きい声出して歌っちゃえば
カラオケでストレスは発散できるぞとかね
そんなことで治るもんじゃないんですよ
カラオで歌っちゃうと
それでストレス溜まりますよ
かっこよく歌わなくちゃいけないんだから
それで見栄が出てきますから
それまたストレスなんですよ
じゃあ踊ってストレス発散しようと思ったら発散できません
バカになるだけ バカみたいに踊るだけで
それでかっこよく踊らなくちゃいけないんだから
猿のように踊っちゃったらみんなに笑われちゃうんだよと言って
それまた訓練するんです
踊りのやり方 それまたストレスでしょうに
そんなものでストレス解放っていうのは
発散っていうのはもうインチキもいいところですよ
ストレス自体が不善なんです
だからもう大胆なことを言いますけど
これは仏教で宗教でよく言うでしょ
悪いことをすると地獄に落ちるんだと
だからストレスの塊で死んじゃえば地獄に落ちる
だよと まあまあ冗談ですけど
そういうふうに言えます
でも冗談でもないんです
ストレスは不戦なんです
不戦行為なんです 早くもそれはもう取って
心がすごい柔軟性のある性格
心っていう場合は性格で覚えてください
柔軟性ある性格 いつでももう笑顔がある性格
常に楽しみを感じる性
感じる性格 人を言うことについて
ああ いいですよということでもなく
もうダメですよ なんでそんなこと言うんでしょうとかね
そういう怒りも欲も出さないで
そういうことですかとちゃんと聞く性格
落ち着いている性格 だから常に落ち着いている性格がストレスのない性格なんです
まあそういうことで 貪瞋痴があるんだから
人間は自由がない 貪瞋痴の奴隷
欲しいものを追って生きていかなくちゃいけない
自由に生きていられない
嫌いなものを壊すために生きていけない
生きて生きていかなくちゃいけないんですよ
そうすると 生きる道がもう決めてしまっちゃうんです
自由っていうのは失っちゃう
自由を失っちゃうと それにあるのは苦しみ
束縛 まあまあ それぐらいの話ですから
それでこの紹介する文章にあったような
この我慢とかね 言葉がありますけどね
それはもう悪 もうはっきりとストレスの言葉なんですね
我慢するのは 嫌なことを我慢する
はっきりしているでしょうに
だから なんでもともと嫌なことあるんですかね
だから根本的に頭の中で何か間違ってます
我慢する場合は嫌なことは我慢するんだから
例えば病気になって体が痛いと
まあ少々我慢しなさいよと
まあ言葉では別に問題ないんだけど
その場合でも なんで病気は嫌だと思うんですかね
それは自然的なことだから
まあ自然なことで 私はこういうこういう病気になりましたと
ですから こういうところ
こういうところ こういうところがものすごい痛いんですよと
なるほど これが病気の状態だと
そうやってクールで見れば
中立的に見れば 我慢ということは成り立たなくなっちゃうんですね
だから物事っていうのはそんなもんだよと
もう簡単に見ておけば
我慢する必要ないんです
まあ頑固っていうのは
もう本当にもう まああまりね
まあそれはもう頭が悪いということで
人の話は聞かないし まあたとえいくら間違っていたとわかっても
それは変えないというね
まあ性格だからね まあそれは頭の悪いという証拠ですよ
決して美しい言葉でもなんでもないんです
例えば我々男たちっていうのは
年取ればどんどん頑固になるでしょ
で どんどん怠けちゃうんですね
新しいものを聞きたくないとかね
新しいものを知りたくないとか
というふうに このまあもう死ぬ準備ですからね
まあ男性の体っていうのは
早くも早くも死に準備するんだから
もうもう見たっても意味がないし
どうせ死ぬことだから
心ではわかっていないので
無意識ではその準備するんですね
そうするとみんなに頑固で見えちゃうんですよ
だから頑固おやじやらという言葉はあるんだけど
頑固ババアとかあまりないんですね
でも実際は女性の方はものすごい頑固なんです
平等だからどちらということはないんですけど
なんで男にそのレッテルを貼られるかというと
だいたい元気な時は頑固じゃないんですよ
もうすぐもう合わせちゃうんです
いろんなことに興味もあるし
知らないことだったらすぐそれまあ勉強してみる
子供でも遊びましょうと言ったら
すぐ子供の年に戻って
すぐガキの頃に戻って遊んであげたりもします
その時だから 突然 ある日突然
もう嫌ですよと 人の話聞かなくなる
孫の話聞かなくなる その時はもう頑固というレッテルが貼られてしまいます
女性の場合は生まれつきだから
もう別に貼れるとこはないんです
貼るとこ ですから この頑固という性格っていうのは
もう物事を判断しないという
頭の悪いという証拠なんです
ですから 本当は仏教の世界は無常の世界を語っているんだから
毎日物事は変わる いろんなものが変わる
古いものは消える 新しいものは生まれてくる
だから常に心を開いておけば
何のこともないんです
もう何のことなく調整しながら生きていられます
いわゆる流れと一緒にいればいいんです
物事はもう瞬間たりとも止まることなく変化していくんです
それにはやっぱり知恵が必要なんですよ
知恵っていうのは大したことではないんですよ
この貪瞋痴で見ないで
そのまんまで余計な判断しないでいれば知恵なんです
例えば Aさんが悪い人やと言われる
あ そうですか だったらもう彼と商売をやめましょうと
もう判断して決めつけて終わっちゃう
それが無知なんです 知恵というのは何も考えないこと A
さんが悪い人ですよと言ったら
あ この人がAさんが悪い人ですよと言っています
で終わり 何も判断しない
それであなた聞いてますけど
聞いてますよ ちゃんと
あなたがAさんが悪い人ですよと言っているんだから
聞いてますよと まあ失礼ですけど
なぜ悪いと言うんでしょうかと
証拠があるんだったら言ってくださいと
それだけで大体問題は終わります
それで証拠を聞いたら
それは客観的な証拠か
本人の判断かとちゃんとわかりますからね
客観的な証拠はあっても
だからとその人を悪いということじゃなくて
それはちゃんと調べて見なくちゃいけないんだと
だから 情報は情報だけで止まってもらう
その楽な生き方は知恵の生き方なんです
そこで仏教は この忍耐という言葉がよく使います
忍耐はおそらくパーリ語でカンティーだと思います
で カンティーというのはこのサンスクリット語でシャンティと言うんですよ
で ヒンドゥー教の人々があの挨拶する時でも
あのシャンティ シャンティと言うんですよ
シャンティ まあいろいろちょっと言語に行っちゃうと
ちょっともうややこしくなります
まあぴったし似てはないんですけど
サンティ サンティとシャンティ
別な言葉ですけど シャンティというまた違う言葉があります
パーリ語でカンティーというのはそのシャンティなんで
サンスクリット語でシャンティはサンティになります
カンティーって忍耐って何でしょうかね
これは平和ですよ 心の
我慢には似ていますけど
平和ということなんです
すごいちょっと機能が違うんです
で よくお釈迦様は比丘たちに我々に言うのは
忍耐しなさいよと 何を？例えば寒い時
暑い時とかね もう蚊がいっぱいいる時とか
虫に刺されたりとかね
でお腹ご飯がもらわなかった時とかね
人にいろいろ批判されたり
非難されたりするとかとかね
忍耐しなさいよと ということは
我慢しろということではなくて
平和でいなさいよと だからシャンティっていうのは
人に褒めてもらうと舞い上がることもよくない
心に波が生まれるんですよ
舞い上がっちゃうと物事見えなくなっちゃうんですね
智慧が消えちゃうんです
だからあんまり舞い上がらない
平和でいる それで悪いことに出会う場合はね
お釈迦様はすごい立派な例えなんですよ
すごい寒さ 激しい寒さに出会うとかね
で 激しい暑さに出会うとか
いろいろ虫に刺されるとかね
まあ瞑想できるところじゃないんですね
きつくて その時も あ 嫌だ
なんでこんなことになるんでしょうか
瞑想もできないんではないかとか
そうやっていらだち作っちゃうと平和が消えちゃうんですね
だから この我々生きている上でいろいろトラブルには出会います
いつでも落ち着いていることは忍耐なんです
楽しいんだからと山を登っても
そこで遭難してしまうということもあり得る
その時 ああ どうでしょうか
大変だと言って暴れ回っちゃうと
怯え倒しちゃうと死んじゃいますから
落ち着いて  そんなことがあるんだと
落ち着いていると 次にどうするべきでしょうか
という道が見えてくる
だからシャンティというのはそういうこと
これ すごい立派な人にしかできないことなんですね
褒めても舞い上がらない
けなされても機嫌が悪くしない生き方
昔のお坊さんたち 托鉢して生活していたんだから
ご飯もらったら まあなんのことなく
今日はよかった 今日は運が
なんて言いますか 今日は空いてるんだとかね
そんなもう俗人の言葉は話しません
なんのことなく これは召し上がる
で 次の日行ったら何もないと
言ったら なんのことなく帰る
こんなお腹が空いても 1 日 1 食なのに
どうしよう どうしようと
それはないんです ある日
お釈迦様はある村に托鉢に行ったんですよ
そこでまあ エピソードはこうなっているんです
マーラが仏教の邪魔する悪神がいるんですね
もう悪魔という意味というよりも
悪神ですよ で かなり仏教に対しても反発する
で 来て この人々に乗りうすって托鉢に何もお布施しなかったんです
で お釈迦様は鉢を洗って村に入ったんだけど
村に入って一つ回って何もない
それで洗ったまんまで戻ってくるんですね
戻ってくるで お釈迦様に直接して
この神に喋られますからね
で お釈迦様にこう言うんですね
あの人々は忙しかったんだよと
あなたが托鉢した時は
今はちゃんと料理もできています
もう一度行けば結構ご馳走いただけますよと
言ったらマーラに叱るんで
お釈迦様は ブッダがね
もう2回行くと思いますか？と
ご飯をもらうために もう一回行ってみますとかね
ないんだと ご飯があってもなくても
私には別に何の問題もないんだよと
お前みたいな欲に溺れている人ではないんだよというふうに答えるんですよ
二度とまた托鉢に行かなかったんです
だから何も思ってないんです
その日はもう食事はなしと
だからそれが仏教でいう忍耐です
それが最高の修行でありますよ
だから簡単にみんなに実践できます
いろいろ 例えば外はすごいうるさいとかね
夜寝て寝ている時って
誰かが騒音出してね オートバイでも走っていたりとかね
その時は苛立ったりとかね
しないで 心の平和を守る
何かいいことあったんだからって舞い上がっちゃってね
もう我を忘れるのではなくて
心の平和を保つ それが忍耐なんです
で 次の言葉はこのヴィリヤだと思います
努力っていうのは ヴィリヤっていうのは怠けの反対なんですよ
怠けの反対 怠けって何でしょうか
怠けにパーリ語で 名詞にしちゃうとアールシアンになりますけどね
またいろいろ各変化はありますからね
有名なパマーダという言葉もあります
アラシアンは怠け パマーダっていうのは
この何でしたっけ？放逸
放逸 そちらの反対で努力という
で あの前の説明で そこら辺にはもう一応なぜ努力しなくちゃいけないかっていうことをね
パマーダ この怠ける人が何するんでしょうかね
怠けて怠けるってことは
何もやってないってことなんですね
でも我々は時間に追われているでしょうに
時間足らないでしょうに
その上怠けるととんでもない結果になるんです
で この努力ってどういうことかと
この時間はっていうのは
ずっと止まることなく変わっていくんです
自分の寿命も止まることなく変わっていくんです
周りの情報も止まることなく変わっていくんです
だから落ち着いていられないんです
その瞬間瞬間でやるべきことをやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから掃除する時間来たら
そのすぐ掃除をすること
でないと後で大変なストレス溜まることになります
で これも人生の失敗の一つなんですよ
例えば やるべきことを後回しにするでしょ
後でしても意味がないんです
なぜならば 時間変わっていくんだから
例えば確定申告は 13 日になっている
その日で出さなくちゃいけない
まあ後にしますと言って
もう 25 日に行く もう遅いでしょうに
ですから 後回しは成り立たないんです
お腹が空いたらご飯を食べるんであって
明日の分まで今日食べるということは成り立たないんです
そう が この時間と物事の変化ということが全然気にしない
よく私にも言うんでしょう
日本人というのはあなた方と違ってちゃんと時間に厳密だよとかね
私は冗談言ってほしくないという立場ですけどね
時計に追われているだけで
結局は徹底的に怠けているんですけど
それが時計見て追われていることじゃなくて
それがストレスでしょうに
その瞬間で その瞬間でやるべきことをその瞬間でやらなくちゃいけないんです
私の場合は こちらに来る途中で車に跳ねられてでも
足でも折ったならば 私はそのまま病院に行くんであって
こちらは来ません いくら待っていたっても
やっぱり物事というのはそんなもんで
そんな時計に合わせてやれるとできないんですよ
何が起こるかわからないんです
その場でそれを処理しておかないと
明日はダメです 今日 スーパーからスーパーじゃなくてコンビニから弁当買ってきたら
まあ今日は時間ないんだから
じゃあ明後日ぐらい食べましょうと
とはダメです その時間でそれ食べなくちゃいけないんです
で 物事っていうのはそういうことで
我々は怠けちゃう 後回しにする
そうすると やるべきことをやってないことになる
それで人生そのものが不幸になってしまう
子供を叱るべき瞬間で叱らないと
後でもう大変な不幸になるんです
どんなものにでもぴったし時間
今の今の瞬間だよと だから人生っていうのは
まあやっぱりボールが向こうから出しちゃうと
ゆっくりじゃあ捕まってみようかなっていうか
捕まりませんでしょうに
そのボールが自分のところに来る瞬間があるんですよ
その瞬間で手がちゃんとそちらにあってほしいんですよ
そうするとボールのキャッチできるんです
それを忘れるなよと 先に手を出して取ったそうといっても
ボールは後から来るんだったら取られていないし
あるいはほんのほんの瞬間でも遅くなったら取るんだけど
もう行ってるんです ボールが
それが宇宙の法則であって
どうにもならない こちらも変わっていくし
物事も変わっていくんです
ですから この瞬間を失うなよと
それはパーリ語でこう言うんです
カナン その瞬間 マーっていうのは流れっていうことをあなた方はウパッジャガーっていうのは失うこと
その中へと それが努力ということなんです
別に踏ん張るということでもないんです
常に目が覚めていること
皆様にこのヴィパッサナー瞑想を通して教えているのは努力なんです
瞬間瞬間ちゃんと取っておけと
後回しにするなよと そういうことで
仏教ではこの大変 このアーラベテニッカメテという
もうすごい努力に関わる言葉があります
で ブッダにしたっても
ブッダが４５年間しか説法しなかったし
その瞬間でちゃんと覚えて帰れと
後で聞きますと言ったら
誰が死ぬかわからないんですよ
だから仏教の努力というのも大変いいことで
損はしません 例えば 今私は喋ってますけど
その時間で他のことをできません
だからせんべい食べたい気持ちはあるかもしれませんだけど
ちょっと無理ですから
そんな余計なことを考えないで
この時間で話をじっと聞いておくと
もう儲かったことなんですよ
損はしていないんです
それが努力というんです
2キロしか歩けない人が4キロを歩く歩くということは努力と言うのは
あれはバカと言うんです
足も弱いのに 腰も弱いのに
心臓も弱いのに 山を登るんだったら
さすが素晴らしい努力家と言わない
私は言わない とんでもないアホやと
それが努力とは言わないんです
努力っていうのは 講演の間では講演を聞く
終わったらじーっと また終わっても待っている必要ないんですよ
終わったらわいわいと言いたいことを言ったり
もうそれはその時 話終わったらじーっと静かにいたっても
それまたおかしいんでしょうに
逆に話しゃべっている時で
いちいちごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ喋っちゃうと
それまた行儀が悪くておかしいでしょうに
そうすると人生は損します
成功できません だから
その 1 秒で その 1 分でやるべきことをやっておきなさいよというブッダの教え
努力っていうのはそういうことなんです
じゃあそこで話を終了いたしますけど
最後にこの幸せ 幸福って何でしょうか
っていうのはね 幸せっていうのは
本当にこの美味しいものを食べることでもないし
たくさんのお金があることでもないし
この体をいじることじゃないんです
幸せっていうのは心の状態なんです
心で充実感が出てくるかと
おにぎり食べても もう高級レストランでもう 10万円のディナーを食べてもどうでもいいんですよ
あなたの心がそれで充実感感じるか感じないかと
だからブッダと弟子たちがもう人が捨てた食べ物でも食べて
木の下で寝て 私こそ幸せやと言っていたんだから
なぜならば 瞬間瞬間の充実感を感じながら
貪瞋痴がない生き方していたんだからなんです
この体を楽しめることはものすごく退屈になるんです
みんなわかってないだけやと思います
映画見るのは楽しい 音楽聴くのは楽しいと
あれは勘違いであって
よく聞いてみてください
退屈になるんです ストレス溜まるんですよ
映画見るのは楽しいんだけど
ポップコーンやらね いっぱい持って行って
それパクパク食べて もうカロリーもいっぱい食べて溜まってしまっちゃうんです
楽しいんだったらそれ見て楽しんでほしいんだけど
結局ストレス溜まるんですよ
音楽でも同じことで 食べることも同じことで
かなりストレス溜まっちゃう
だからこの五欲を楽しむ
五欲に溺れることが不幸なんです
充実感感じられるか それがやったぞという気持ちなんですよ
映画見に行っても ちゃんと映画を見る
ちゃんとそれを理解もする
そうすると 何を見たかも知ってるし
監督が何言いたかったいたんでしょうか
知ってるし 映画のからくりもちゃんと知ってるし
いろいろ工夫やら技術やらね
各映画で使っているでしょうに
歴史的な映画だったら
本当に歴史はそのまま語っているか
あるいはどこまで新しく変えているかとか
そこまでも知っているし
そうすると 払ったいくらぐらいですかね
わかりません   1,200円は無駄でなくなっちゃいますよ
それでポップコーン食べるわ
コーヒー飲むわ トイレに走っていくわ
また誰かと隣の人としゃべるわと
見てないんですね  1,300円の損
時間の無駄 ですから そのそれで見たら満たそうという充実感が出てきます
それがこの瞬間瞬間 ちゃんと生きている時だけ成り立つものなんです
そういうふうに 我々みんな
この今の瞬間は無駄にしないで
きちんと単純で生きているということで
心に充実感が得られると
それがブッダが教える幸福だよと
すべてやったそうと もうやることもうないんだぞというのは
お釈迦様おっしゃっている涅槃という究極的な解脱であります
そこら辺で話を終了したいと思います
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]